I had to fix a
fracture for a five a 5-year-old
boy so guys if you are somebody who
trains like me when I'm doing boxing
when I'm jogging when I'm do
bodybuilding this can benefit you it's
from Nature's Blends as you guys
know I get my honey my black seed oil
and many other supplements from them it
has 86 plus minerals including zinc
magnesium selenium fic acid 59% fully
lab tested the highest in the market
boost testosterone levels Boost energy
levels and safe for men and women so
check out Nature's Blends in the
description box and enjoy
itam brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshallah
so Israel's
desperation is going to such levels that
they now have some mosad agent SL uh
this V woman pretending to be a
Palestinian uh doctor working in the
alaa hospital as you can see let's see
if she's going to win the Oscar with
this drama that she has learned from her
evil forefathers this Zionist scums the
genocidal individuals who were killing
innocent men women and children and
babies as you can see they are losing
this war in every single ground and as
you can see brother and sisters watch
this video for yourself yeah Allah I can
believe I'm doing this but the world has
to know has to know what Hamas is making
here they're taking over the entire
Hospital they're taking over the fuel
the
medicine I have nothing to treat
with I had to fix a
fracture for a five a 5-year-old
boy without
morphe because ham took it to
themselves Ya
Allah
please please if
you if you hear me please leave run away
don't
stay
please Allah so guys as you can see
Subhan Allah the desperation that they
are in that she pretends to be you know
and she's this doctor and everything
looks so clean Subhan Allah you know the
doctors there are working with Blood
Sweat and Tears literally you can see
the sincerity in their eyes from the way
they talk these doctors are even writing
their names on their arms because they
know that's the only way they'll be
identified to be buried to know this is
the level what's going on in Gaza
brothers and sisters and you've got
these individuals who are your lame and
Zionist by the way who are mocking the
death of these innocent Palestinian men
women children and kids and babies for
that matter and now we've got them
pretending to be doctors crying and you
know this crocodile tears we are not
buying it and you are losing this war
and the whole entire world and you will
go down in history as individuals who
committed genocide and Massacre against
these innocent people who you stole
their land pushed them out killed them
indiscriminately and you are
collectively punishing all of them and
the whole world can see this brothers
and sisters we urge you guys to carry on
exposing them what we are doing in the
social media is hurting them so bad that
they do not know what to do and
desperate times call for desper measures
measures and that is exactly what's
going on so brother and sisters Carry On
The Campaign inallah and donate towards
your brothers and sisters there's a link
in the description box may Allah subhana
bless and preserve you guys inshallah
carry on we are going to expose them at
every opportunity we have to this mad
spyagent dirt bag you got exposed that's
what you've done you've got exposed
nothing you just showed the desperation
of your genocidal
country